[Music]
this is me at the end of college
so anyway so today i'm packing up my
room is absolutely disgusting
uh there's dust all over the place
unbelievable how much dust this place
accumulates
just unreal 21 year old me was
apparently fascinated by dust
but where does it all come from well in
this video
we are going to get to the bottom of
this now this video was sponsored by
google
and when they approached me about
sponsoring a video i suggested i show
you
how i use google to research a complex
question
after all research is just research
anyway i couldn't pick a simple question
like how far away is the moon
how old is derek muller or how much wood
could a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck
could chuck wood
because the video would be over already
but in the space of all possible queries
questions like these with clear
unambiguous answers are by far in the
minority
in fact of all the billions of search
queries typed into google every day
fully 15 are ones that google
has never even seen before so google
never actually gives you answers instead
in just a fraction of a second it uses
algorithms to select the most relevant
information from the hundreds of
billions of web pages it has indexed
what you do with that information is up
to you
so for this video i intentionally
selected something surrounded by
myths dust unbelievable
so a while back when i was filming a
different video a
phd scientist told me you know 70 of
household dust is dead skin
and i'd heard that before and chances
are you have two
if you type is dust into google the top
autocomplete result is
dead skin because that's one of the most
common ways people complete that query
but a quick scan of this page suggests
that the claim
is not true it's a misconception from
live science
sometimes a specific percentage of dust
is said to be dead skin
usually about 70 or 80 percent but
unless you're a molten bird or
reptile or you work in dr frankenstein's
laboratory
very little of your environment is
composed of dead body parts
or bbc science magazine which asks what
is dust made of
think it's human skin think again the
article says
it's a misconception that it's mostly
from outside the rest is
carpet fluff and clothes fibers and sure
enough all over the web you'll find
people debunking this idea
so is that it case closed hardly
i mean i'm not just gonna do one search
and call it a day
it's important to be aware of your own
biases
when i started this search the claim
seemed false
the idea that 70 to 80 of dust is dead
skin
it's exactly the sort of thing that is
gross enough to spread as an urban
legend
but it just seems implausible i mean if
most dust is dead skin
then why do abandoned buildings get
dusty over time
the debunking claims fit my
preconceptions so it would be easy to
stop here
but you got to be careful not just to
search to confirm what you already
thought
a common mistake people make is putting
the answer they are looking for
right in the search query looking more
closely
these websites lack scientific papers as
references
and i'm curious if the idea that 70 to
80 of dust
is dead skin if that's totally wrong
then how did the myth get started in the
first place
surely some dust must be dead skin but
how much
well a good strategy is to start broad
how do you define
dust exactly well dust is generally
defined as
particles that can become airborne for a
significant period of time
when perturbed by natural forces but how
long
is a significant period of time and what
are
natural forces exactly so the definition
of dust has
fuzzy boundaries kind of like dust
itself
if you ask the question how big is a
dust particle you get different answers
the international standardization
organization defines dust as any
particle smaller than 75 micrometers in
diameter
that's roughly the width of a human hair
the glossary of atmospheric chemistry
terms includes anything up to
100 micrometers but i've found several
papers that
include particles as large as two
millimeters
this large discrepancy is due to the
fact the most important property of a
dust particle
is not its size but its settling
velocity
which then determines how long it can
stay airborne
a 100 micrometer metal ball would fall
to the ground very quickly while a two
millimeter long cotton fiber could float
on
indoor air currents indefinitely so to
get around the different sizes
shapes and densities of dust particles
the international standardization
organization
has a way of calculating an effective
diameter
they define it as the diameter of a
hypothetical sphere of density one gram
per centimeter cubed
having the same terminal settling
velocity in calm
air as the particle in question
regardless of its geometric size
shape and true density
by any of these metrics a single human
skin cell with an average diameter of
around 30 micrometers
would count as dust so then how many
dead skin cells
are we shedding you'd think the average
rate of skin shedding would be well
established
but the internet is a tangled web of
misquotations and missing citations when
it comes to skin
in trying to answer this question i
found dozens of web articles saying we
shed anywhere between
30 000 skin cells per day to 300 000
skin cells per minute
and estimated weights of dead skin as
high as nine pounds a year
per person using google scholar a great
resource for searching published
scientific research
i was able to track down several
peer-reviewed sources that agreed on the
numbers
every hour you create about 20 million
new skin cells
as those new skin cells form they push
older cells
up through the layers of the epidermis
and over a period of weeks they flatten
out
and harden forming the barrier that
protects our bodies from the outside
world
ultimately these dead skin cells fall
off usually
one by one for healthy skin so we
are constantly molting like a snake we
just don't notice it because our skin
comes off one cell at a time
fun fact dead skin cells are shed more
rapidly from your forearms than from
your back
and more rapidly from your back than
from your abdomen and one of the ways
scientists have measured
these rates of skin shedding is actually
by taping containers
onto people's skin
and collecting up the dead skin cells
shed over at least a 48 hour period
yeah i'm gonna regret this based on
these measurements we know that each
square
centimeter of your body is shedding
around a thousand dead skin cells per
hour
now the average adult body has a surface
area of nearly two
square meters meaning you are shedding
nearly 20
million dead skin cells per hour that
adds up to
half a billion dead skin cells per day
now half a billion dead skin cells
weigh between one and two grams that's
just
a little bit less than the weight of a
penny
over a year that means you shed half a
kilogram or over
a pound of dead skin if you want to
think about it another
way in a single year you give off around
180 billion
dead skin cells that's roughly the same
number
as there are stars in our milky way
galaxy
an average family of 2.6 people could
cover the entire horizontal surface of
an average 2 000 square foot home
with a layer of skin cells one cell deep
in around
200 days that is assuming all their dead
skin cells accumulate around the house
which of course is not true some will
come off in the shower and some will get
captured in clothes and bed sheets and
be
rinsed out in the wash not to mention
dead skin cells shed outside the home
still the amount of skin we shed is not
small
but how much is it as a percentage of
household dust
well that turns out to be a trickier
question because there are a lot of
other sources of dust like
pollen fibers from rugs clothes and
furniture
dirt from outside even micro meteorites
dust from space
[Music]
to clear things up i called around to
some dust experts
and they pointed me to this book house
dust biology
by johanna van brunswick from 1981 and
sure enough on page 37 there is
this graph now it appears to show the
fraction of skin particles in
airborne dust as 80 except
not really this is a stacked area graph
so dead skin accounts for only 20
percent of dust particles between
100 and 300 micrometers could a simple
misunderstanding of this graph be the
source of the urban legend
i mean it's possible but what's more
interesting to me
is that the legend is not that far off
according to this a full
50 of dust particles under 100
micrometers
is dead human skin the book also reports
on a study
where they vacuumed a mattress and
studied the resulting dust ball under
the microscope
53 of the dust was skin particles
so the debunkers are debunked while not
70 to 80 percent dead skin cells do make
up a significant portion of household
dust
of course the exact percentage depends a
lot on how much other dust is
contributed by the environment
these studies were conducted in houses
in the netherlands which
typically have hardwood floors and
therefore less dust than homes with
carpeting
it also depends on how large of a
particle you consider
dust dead skin cells account for roughly
half
of the small dust particles but much
less than half of what is sucked up by
your vacuum cleaner
oh that is gross unbelievable
i guess it makes sense that the place
where we find the most dead skin cells
is
in and around our beds where we spend a
third of our lives
shedding a third of our skin in our
sleep
so then is it true that your mattress
actually doubles in weight every
10 years this claim was actually
published in a major news outlet 20
years ago
with the increase in mass attributed to
dust mites that feed on your dead skin
the claim which lacked a scientific
reference is so disgusting it has spread
throughout the internet
but it's not true if two people slept on
the same bed for a decade
and even if all their dead skin cells
ended up in the mattress
it would only gain around three
kilograms or seven pounds
and by conservation of mass the dust
mites that feed off that dead skin
could not weigh more than that so the
total weight gain would have to be less
than 10 percent the weight of an average
mattress
and remember dead skin cells are small
and light enough to become
airborne just making the bed has been
found to increase the number of skin
flakes in a cubic meter of air
from 21 000 to 107 000
skin scale dust is inevitable and it
occurs in higher quantities
where there are more people scientists
have studied the airborne dust in the
london underground and found that
fragments of dead skin cells
make up around 10 percent of all small
dust particles by weight
and it's not just skin we are shedding a
ton of tiny organisms
live on our bodies a teeming microbiome
of
bacteria fungi and mites every hour we
shed approximately one million
microbes in a cloud that spreads out a
radius of about 1 meter from
our bodies in one study an individual
was placed in a clean room for 90
minutes
scientists then identified who had been
in the room
not using their dna but rather using the
characteristic fingerprint of their
microbial cloud
the technique was so accurate the team
wrote that it
clearly suggests a forensic application
for indoor bioaerosols
meaning that one day we will likely use
microbial dust clouds to solve crimes
dust can reveal a lot about us because
a significant fraction of it literally
is us
i mean everyone has heard the expression
dust to dust but
they're probably not thinking about how
each and every day
part of us is becoming dust
you know when i was reading this house
dust biology book i found
some sections that sounded to me a
little bit like poetry
so studying uh dust from an office under
a light microscope
revealed tree fibers from paper eraser
dust
rubber calcite and pumice human hair
various dyed wools cottons and synthetic
fibers such as
nylon rayon cellulose triacetate and
orlon dander tobacco cigarette ashes
graphite
wood shavings oil soot paint chips
glue fingernail filings and traces of
quartz
and starch i love all these words
because they bring
vivid images to mind it's like the
tiniest fragments of our lives can paint
a full picture of reality
of who was there and what they did
you know searching through dust is a
little like searching the internet
there are so many pieces it's fuzzy
nebulous
but with the right tools and a bit of
perseverance i'm confident that
we can uncover the truth buried in there
in this case the truth is that dust
particularly these small particles and
dust around beds is mostly dead skin
why does that matter because it is
something we can be certain about
i mean for centuries science has beaten
back the shrouds
of ignorance and knowing what is really
true
is the only way we have been able to
make progress
the internet gives us a great
opportunity to
share that knowledge but only if someone
takes the time to
research and establish what really
is true
to perform a lot of this research i have
of course been using google
which might make you wonder how they
figure out what to show you in the first
place
well good news google is not a black box
they have an entire website that takes
you
under the hood of the search engine and
explains all the testing and
improvements they make
check it out by clicking the link in the
description and
when you go to make your next search try
it a few different ways
start broad don't include your answer in
the query use
image search and most importantly
remember google shows you the most
relevant information
it's up to you to decide what to do with
it
thanks to google for sponsoring this
video learn more about search by
clicking the link in the description